wer wird eigentlich dem bundeskanzler
die bundeskanzlerin
obwohl es manchmal anders wird wer
regierungschefin wird können wir nur
indirekt beeinflussen also wir
entscheiden bei der bundestagswahl wie
das parlament zusammengesetzt wird das
parlament entscheidet dann wer kanzler
oder kanzlerin wird dazu braucht der
kandidat beziehungsweise die kandidatin
die absolute mehrheit dh die zustimmung
von mehr als der hälfte der abgeordneten
ich hab das nicht würden sich weitere
wahl phasen anschließen bisher gab es
aber immer im ersten wahlgang schon eine
entscheidung denkt man schon vor der
wahl anhaltspunkte hat wer
regierungschefin werden könnte stellen
einige parteien eine kanzlerkandidatin
oder einen kanzlerkandidaten auf bislang
wurde auch immer jemand gewählt er
vorher aufgestellt wurde rein
theoretisch könnte der bundestag aber
auch eine ganz andere person wählen